welcome to this video about algebraic
restriction codes and their applications
my name is cesco and this is joint work
with divish nico mohammad giulio and
machi
first i'm going to introduce algebraic
restriction codes then i will show you
how we use them inside of cryptography
and finally and we're going to show you
a construction of an algebraic
restriction code
imagine you have a device
where on input x0 and x1
where both of these are vectors
this device is supposed to publish a
times x0 plus x1
where a is a scalar this device however
can misbehave and instead of multiplying
the scalar a
multiply an arbitrary matrix a to x0 and
publish the result and this is what we
want to stop with algebraic restriction
codes
so what we do instead is use some
randomness r to encode x0 and x1
into x0 head and x1 hat then we send
this off to the device
the device will publish
a x0 hat plus
x1 hat
now we also publish r
and the public can reconstruct
a x0 plus x1 from these two
values
if however
the device misbehaves now
and publishes
a times x0 head plus
x1 hat
the public cannot reconstruct
small a times x0
plus x1
or any other value
dependent on x0 or x1
now that was an example
now i'm going to go into the definition
of algebraic restriction codes
we have two sets of functions
f which is a subset of g
f contains all the functions that the
device is supposed to be able to
evaluate
g however contains all the functions
that the device can actually evaluate an
algebraic restriction code has two
algorithms
an encoding algorithm which uses some
randomness to encode its input x
into x hat
then a function from either of those two
sets
can be
evaluated on the encoded input
this results in an encoded output
the encoded output can then using the
same randomness as before
be
decoded again
now this is correct
if for every function in f
the decoded value is the same as if you
evaluated the function
on the original
input
however
if you use a function outside of f but
inside of g
then the output of the decoded
value
should be uniformly random
now i'm going to show you how we use
algebraic restriction codes in
cryptography namely embedding a
oblivious transfer protocol
oblivious transfer is a two-party
protocol between a receiver and a sender
the receiver contributes a choice bit b
and the sender contributes two strings
m0 and m1
and at the end of the protocol the
receiver learns
m
b
however she does not learn
m one minus b
and the sender does not learn b
oblivious transfer is
interesting as it is sufficient to build
arbitrary secure multi-party computation
protocols
using algebraic restriction codes we can
build a rate one statistically send a
private to message oblivious transfer
protocol without any setup assumptions
or just under the decisional
diffie-hellman assumption
to understand the oblivious transfer
protocol i first going to explain to you
linearly homomorphic encryption
a linearly homomorphic encryption
is a special kind of public key
encryption a public key encryption
scheme
has two keys a public key pk and a
secret key sk
the public key here is used to encrypt a
message m into a
ciphertext then
the secret key sk can be used to
retrieve the message back from the
ciphertext in the scheme i'm talking
about currently the messages are n by n
matrices
over the integers modulo p
a linearly homomorphic encryption scheme
additionally has the ability to modify
the ciphertext using the
vectors a and b such that if you modify
it
you get a new ciphertext c prime
and if you decrypt the new ciphertext c
prime using the secret key again you get
the original plaintext m multiplied by a
plus b
a and b here are the vectors from this
evaluation procedure now i'll show you
the linearly homomorphic encryption
scheme already is almost an oblivious
transfer protocol
the receiver simply multiplies its
choice bit b by an identity matrix of
size n
and then encrypts it inside of the
linearly homomorphic encryption scheme
it sends the ciphertext together with
the public key to the sender
the sender then evaluates a function
which multiplies
m1 minus m0 to b and adds m0 this is
evaluated on the ciphertext and yields a
new ciphertext c prime this new
ciphertext c prime is then sent to the
receiver who can simply decrypt it
and
retrieve mb
the main problem with this setup however
is that if the receiver wants to cheat
she can simply
encrypt an arbitrary matrix a and send
it to the sender
if the sender then goes ahead and does
the same thing as before multiplying by
m1 minus m0 and adding m 0
the receiver can learn the result of
this function which she is not supposed
to learn
this already sounds a lot like the
problem i've outlined earlier an
adversary can
multiply by an arbitrary matrix instead
of just a scalar
now we can stop this by using algebraic
restriction codes
now we simply modify the protocol by
first encoding m0 and m1 to m0 head and
m1 head
then
if the receiver encrypts the matrix
b times
identity matrix
and the evaluator
evaluates the function multiplying by m1
hat minus m0 and adding m0
the receiver learns
mb head
and can decode it using the randomness r
to mb
if however the receiver encrypts a
matrix which is not a scaled unit matrix
the receiver
will only learn
a times
m one hat minus m0 hat
plus
m0
as we know from the definition of
algebraic restriction codes
this will result in a uniformly random
value
finally i want to take a look at our
explicit constructions of algebraic
restriction codes
the first one is the one that we've
already looked at
where the
allowed set of functions simply scale x0
by
a scalar and add x1
but the possible functions are the
functions where x0 is multiplied by an
arbitrary matrix and x1 is
added you know in our second
construction
the allowed functions
take the input and multiply it by an
arbitrary matrix
however the
functions which are possible to apply
are actually all compressing functions
at this point i want to note that
compressing in a sense is necessary
because if the set of evaluatable
functions contains
injective functions
then they are invertible and the notion
of algebraic restriction codes are
impossible now i quickly want to go over
the first construction
in this construction we get two inputs
x0 and x1 each of length n
what we do is we sample a uniformly
random matrix of size
n times m where m is bigger than n
then we sample
x zero hat and x one hat such that r
times x zero head is x zero and
r times x one hat is x one then we can
simply
evaluate the
possible functions which
multiply an arbitrary matrix a to x0 hat
and add x1 hat
and decode by
multiplying r again
you should know that if a is a scaled
unit matrix
then
r times
a times unit matrix
times x0 head plus x1 hat
this r
distributes into these
and can be swapped around with this
scalar
this means that it is equal to this
expression and because how x0 hat and x1
hat are defined
this means that it results in a times x0
plus x1
the basic reason why this doesn't work
if a is not a scaled unit matrix is
that
a and r do not commute
the second construction follows a
similar philosophy however it needs a
strengthened version of the xor lemma
if you want more details about the other
algebraic restriction code construction
the choice of linearly homeomorphic
encryption scheme
how we achieve this rate one
how we are able to limit b to
zero and one instead of
the entire
integers modulo p
and a more detailed proof of the
first algebraic restriction code please
check out our paper
and these are the references